my job is to basically be the architect
of the film and to take the words and
turn them into visuals creating
environments for the characters we have
emerged you need to go from this and all
of this to this to this
by trained to be a set designer costume
designer take the take my breath away
when you absolutely an after you've
worked in that space for a day I mean
that becomes real place too initially I
concept the ideas bring the words to
some sort of a visual state and there's
a massive team of people that support me
in that and creating the visuals that
you'll see in not only the sense of
concept and design aspects also
construction on this epic craving all of
those elements are part of what you'll
see in the film and it comes in many
ways location department as well to is
included because if we can't find a
location that works and we have to build
it on stage or the ss7 stage it means a
privilege you know for all of us to be
here historically and and for the great
space to work in the first set we had
there is absolutely vital tracking an
enormous kind of underground station you
can't believe it it's that under the
attention to detail is so fantastic the
narrative of this project is I think
absolutely wonderful it's going to be
groundbreaking it's going to be a new
chapter so it's really about finding
things that are different and exciting
for the audience to look at
you